joining us right now on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line here on
the rich eisen show off of a big time
win for him and the team daniel jones
how are you daniel
i'm doing good rich how are you how loud
was that crowd
how was that scene uh loud uh
they got going uh third downs and
anytime we're down there in the in the
red area they were going so it was a fun
atmosphere to play in i mean where does
that rank for you uh i mean you've
obviously been in this league now two
plus years your third year i mean this
assignment oh and three back against the
wall saints fans in that building for
the first time since 2019
where does that assignment rank for you
daniel
uh it's definitely up there um yeah i
mean i think it's up there uh definitely
towards the top it's not at the top so
um you know we knew it was a big game we
knew uh what the atmosphere would be
like and and you know how fired up
they'd be going in so something we uh
prepared for it was a huge game for us
and
um you know i thought we were ready for
it well and then then the walk-off
then the walk-off in overtime uh where
saquon hits pager uh i couldn't help but
notice
uh as the celebration began that saquon
ran past pretty much everybody until he
found you
uh what's your relationship with him
like daniel jones
uh it's good i mean i think um you know
we've uh
been together now you know two plus
years and um
you know have uh gone through a lot and
he's certainly gone through a lot coming
back from it from his knee injury and
and uh you know just being able to see
up close and personal how hard he he
worked to get back uh what he did on a
day in and day out basis um to get to
where he's at now and then you know i
thought it was was so fitting that he
had the you know the walk off run there
and and uh you know excited for him
excited for this team
um and uh something we've gotta build on
yeah just like the two of you would seem
to have a moment when you said we we
know what he's been through obviously
not just the knee injury but being
drafted so high as a running back uh in
this day and age it's it's kind of an
outlier
what how would you turn what you've been
through daniel jones
um
yeah i mean it's been uh
you know we we obviously had a tough
start to this season um tough start to
last season and
um you know a lot of things we need to
do better and and you know we've been
working on to to improve so
um you know after uh you know losing
three games not getting the results that
uh you know we would have you know hoped
for and expected um like you said kind
of having our backs against the wall
going into new orleans new orleans it
was a big win for us and and uh you know
exciting so we've kind of got to build
off of it going forward no i i i
understand daniel you're a duke man i
went to uh you know michigan you know
i i'm i'm i think i'm on your uh
intellectual wavelength uh you know i
asked about you you mentioned team you
use words like us and stuff like that
what about you i mean you hear what's
going on you hear what people are saying
in the new york metropolitan area about
your third year and how big it is for
you
what would you say you've been through
so far in new york and new jersey daniel
yeah i mean it's uh
playing quarterback in in new york and
and uh representing this franchise is uh
you know it's a highly scrutinized
position and um you know we haven't won
enough games and and uh
you know i uh certainly
um you know need to play better and put
the team in a position to win so i
understand the responsibility and the
expectations of this position and
um
you know i think that's part of it it's
uh
you know it's an exciting opportunity
though to
to be in this mission and have the
opportunity to
to play quarterback in new york play
quarterback for the giants so it comes
with a lot of uh scrutiny and people
um you know looking at uh what you're
doing how you're playing and and uh
you know that's also an opportunity to
to play well and put the team in a
position to win how do you put all that
aside and because you know you've got it
in you right i mean you know you've got
it in you you've got the talent you're
drafted top 10 for a reason you know you
you can run you can throw which is
exactly what you need to succeed in the
21st century you got an all-world
running back there you got some terrific
weapons around how do you place aside
all the the stuff that you're supposed
to be placing aside but human beings
have a difficulty doing daniel jones
yeah i mean i think um
you know it's uh certainly
you know you don't you don't seek any of
the uh any of that out or you know
definitely don't look for it but but you
know kind of what's going on from
talking to uh people in the media doing
press conferences and
um you know but i think the important
thing is focusing on what you're doing
and focusing on
um
you know playing football preparing
practicing every week studying watching
film
um getting getting yourself ready to go
and
you know making sure that what you're
thinking about what's that that's what
you're what you're doing on a day in and
day out basis and um you know knowing
and trusting that that will um you know
show itself on sunday so you don't uh
turn to your burner twitter account and
tweet back at the trolls you're not
doing that daniel
no i'm not i'm not right okay
you weren't upset that instagram went
down yesterday you're not on that sort
of stuff daniel
i i didn't uh i didn't know it you
didn't so you
you did not know instagram and facebook
went down yesterday like literally i
just informed i i did after the fact
yeah after the fact okay i heard someone
talking about it
i just want to make sure uh how is eli
manning influenced you
daniel
how was he influenced um
yeah i mean he he uh
you know i was very fortunate to have
that year with him and see
um
you know how he did it how he carried
himself and and um you know to build
that relationship with him he's had a a
huge impact on me and a huge influence
on me and kind of setting the standard
and showing um
you know how this position is supposed
to be played on the field and also
um you know how to carry yourself off
the field representing this team this
franchise in this city so
um
you know i think uh
you know he's helped me out of time and
uh certainly a relationship i'm
fortunate to have has anyone ever told
you you sound exactly like him daniel
don't know what you told me
i heard that a little bit uh my rookie
year but this is that's probably the
first time in a while i've heard that
well i got to be honest with you daniel
i've interviewed elon manning he was uh
in the league when nfl network started
in 2003 i think this might be just the
same conversation i had with him very
early on in his career you know and
obviously he
he survived it significantly
and yeah and and you are in your third
year right now and that's why i'm i'm
asking you know if if his pass can be
your prologue if you if you know about
that and actually use that to your
advantage
daniel um
yeah i mean i think uh
you know it's certainly something i
could you know
certainly or i'm aware of it and
something to learn from and
like i said he kind of stepped to set
the standard and
uh showed showed the the way of how it's
supposed to be done
um you know in in this position so um i
guess i'll i'll uh i'll take that as a
compliment daniel jones giants
quarterback fresh off the big overtime
win in new orleans here on the rich
eisen show one of my favorite people
i've gotten to meet in the 18 years i've
done this job is your offensive
coordinator and jason garrett i i mean
his disposition i don't know
how you know i'd love to live life like
that you know um it is he is truly
remarkable and
obviously also
under a microscope wherever he's been
how is your relationship with him and
this offense what what are we what what
can we expect
now that you're one month into this year
and obviously year two in what what can
be expected in your relationship with
him and how that can actually affect
some more w's for your
team um yeah i mean i i think uh
i'd certainly second your uh
you know thoughts on him and how
impressive he is on a day in and day out
basis the way he carries himself and
sets the example for for all of us um
you know players especially me
as a quarterback and and uh you know i
have a great relationship with him he's
uh made a huge impact
um on me um these past couple years how
so what does he tell you
how so
uh well i think um
you know i think the example he sets who
he is how consistent he is with his his
attitude his his approach to
football approach to challenges and um
you know making sure we're prepared
every week and
um you know i think he's just you know i
think consistency and how
um how he prepares himself
every day is a huge
uh something we all you know look to uh
certainly i some something i you know
look to
um in my position so i've learned a ton
of football films certainly uh as well
and and um he's been around the game
obviously played uh for a long time and
and uh has been around the game
coaching and had a lot of success so um
learned learned a ton from him
on the field as well so we'll continue
to work and he's something that someone
that uh certainly i have a lot of
faith in and and you know the entire
offense does will continue to work and
and uh develop and so and there's a lot
of talk around the league obviously
coach quarterback uh relationships hc
and qb and you know kirk cousins is now
having a 45-minute weekly meeting with
mike zimmer and the whole brady
belichick thing and how they used to
have meetings and stuff what about you
and joe judge um what's your interaction
with him throughout the week daniel
jones
uh yeah we have a a great relationship
um
coach judge is um
you know very involved in all three
phases of the game he's a special teams
guy
um
you know by trade but certainly you know
it's just a football coach knows a ton
about uh every part of the game so um
you know we we talk every week going in
talk talk about the defense what we see
schematically uh personnel wise
and then how that's going to affect our
game plan so
um you know we're in constant i'd say
constant conversation throughout the
week about the plan and
and uh you know how he sees this game
being played how he sees
um you know my role in that and uh
you know kind of um
you know i'd say it's uh
um
yeah very consistent and constant
conversation throughout the week and
it's just a big week too daniel i mean
it's it's cowboys week they're atop the
division
a win would put you directly back in the
mix we all know that a one in seven
start did not sink your team last year
um i'm i'm wondering how big you think
this game is this week
for you
uh yeah it's a it's an important game
all these divisional games
um are extremely important and and uh
you know we know we've got to prepare
and and play well but but our focus is
on
you know just this week and doing that
and and uh
you know we we uh
got to build off some of the good things
we did last week and correct those
things but um you know focus on what we
got to do to uh to beat dallas and these
are huge games all these divisional
games are huge all right daniel um if
you wouldn't mind doing something for me
before you leave this conversation i
greatly appreciate it i've never asked
anything of you before um so uh you know
i run the 40 yard dash every year
and you had one of the top speeds in the
nfl last year you you you reached i mean
you could have been ticketed in certain
parts of this country
is there any is there any um advice you
can give me on how to run faster daniel
like how do you do it running fast
um well i didn't run a very good 40 at
the combine um would you run and i ran
fast but i also fell so i don't know um
well hold on run hard but but make sure
you you don't run too hard for
um
for your speed i guess don't overrun
your speed okay i don't know maybe maybe
it helps if someone's chasing you well i
was told i was told that by the way that
wouldn't be a bad idea
that would make me faster if someone was
chasing me i like that idea but i've
been told all the time whenever i run
the 40 i should feel like i'm about to
fall over
that's the way i was told because you
know you got to you gotta get out in
front of your hips like you can't you
know that that's what i was told so
maybe i put this all together and you
can be my inspiration
daniel yeah i don't know whatever uh
yeah i don't know i don't know if i'm
the guy listen to that just uh
run like someone's chasing me okay like
someone's chasing me and and i don't
know 481 at the combine sounds like you
uh you got mistimed i'll be honest with
you so i know the feeling maybe we're
closer in lockstep than anything before
daniel thank you thanks for the time uh
congrats on that big w man i know so
many people in the metropolitan area
that you made happy with that and good
luck throughout the season i'd love to
chat again i appreciate it awesome
thanks so much for having me you bet
that's daniel jones everybody uh here on
the rich eisen show hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here